what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we're continuing on with the
flash rebirth and and not really
flattering oh I guess the flash rebirth
but flash work and the whole idea behind
this is remember for those of you guys
who were just now getting into this
flash war deals with the idea that Wally
West discovered that his kids or at
least he was told that his kids were
alive now again this information really
came from hunter zolomon who of course
as we talked about in previous videos
was a speedster who basically became an
enemy of the flash after he had
essentially lost the use of his legs and
one of the flash wally west to go back
and change time so that everything in
hunter zolomon Slice really hadn't gone
awry and gone terrible because of the
fact that Wally wouldn't do it hunter
zolomon became his enemy and so in this
instance hunter zolomon it kind of you
know seemingly grabbed him from from the
present day brought him to the 25th
century and said hey just so you know
Wally like your kids are stuck in the
Speed Force if you go out there and you
destroy the Speed Force you'll bring
them back but he'll basically bring your
kids back and again it's very much
feeding on like the parental instincts
of of Wally West which is why it works
the problem with this was that Barry was
coming from this from the perspective of
like the events of Flashpoint right like
when Barry had gone back in time tried
to save his mom's life he succeeded but
screwed up the universe in the process
and had to go back in time and let her
die in order to set things back to
normal
ah that that's the whole perspective
he's coming from here and trying to
impart those pearls of wisdom on to
Wally the whole idea of Wally is I've
grown
I've grown beyond your protege I'm not
the little kid who was Kid Flash anymore
I'm an adult now with a family that I
need to go save and again it works
because what parent wouldn't go to the
ends of the earth in order to save their
kids the issue with this is when you're
talking about two speedsters of such
incredible ability such incredible speed
running around it's not like they move
in a vacuum right it's not like they
move around and nothing's impacted by
what they do they're running at such a
high velocity around the earth with
Wally running to break the Speed Force
and Barry chasing him down that they're
literally sending ripples throughout the
entirety of the universe itself the very
fabric of the universe is literally
shaking at the the kind of speed and the
kind of ripples are putting off on such
a strong level and so will you have like
Amanda Waller Steve Trevor and the
various members of the government
responding to this and trying to find a
way to deal with it
their initial response is well let's
just kind of use weapon and see if we
can take them out using tanks or
something like that and of course it
doesn't work and so you know this is
like a little one-page thing it's not
designed to be a great big huge sprawled
out event but in response to this you
have Amanda Waller who tell us to use
Trevor
not your friends so of course this
basically means the Justice League but
the important thing about this and the
cool thing with this great big huge
moment is you're talking about two
extremely powerful guys in terms of how
their speed impacts the world around
them the what this is also going to do
is it's really going to kind of
reiterate the status quo in relation to
how fast like Superman is in relation to
these guys and how fast the various
members of the superhero community are
in terms of the power they possess and
so for Superman and the rest of the
Justice League and really even some of
the Titans show up on the scene and say
hey look like what's going on here
they're basically given the news by
Steve Trevor saying that like Wally
wants to break the Speed Force Barry's
chasing him down it's creating ripples
throughout the entire fabric of the
universe you guys have to find a way to
stop him and what ends up happening is
Superman immediately takes off after
them and that's kind of a funny thing
because when Superman races off you know
it's basically like hey you guys have to
stop you guys have to slow down but it
only lasts for like a fraction of a
second I mean it's it's it is so
astronomically quick and Superman has to
back off because he can't keep up and
that's one of the big things that I want
you guys to really bring from this when
it comes to like status quos in comic
books they change all the time and so
really as it's kind of been one of those
things where for the last I would say
probably the last 20 years it's been
generally accepted that the flashes are
faster than Superman because of what use
were the flash be if he's not the
fastest man alive he's just a guy that
can run really fast and so because of
this like it really kind of fits into
the status quo now again going all the
way back to like the 40s 50s 60s and in
really from the 60s going forward
especially with regards to Barry Allen
really from the mid 50s going forward in
the modern day you're talking about like
the flash vs. Superman those races are
iconic ah but really it wasn't until
recent years within the last 10 20 years
or so there's kind of been established
the flash is always faster than Superman
because that's just how fast he is but
from there you switch over to Green
Lantern and Green Lantern responses well
if Superman can't stop them then the big
green wall will bring them to an end and
again they blast right through it I mean
they literally like they tear right
through the Green Lantern's wall and
this is a huge moment this is one of the
things that's this really really crazy
here because when you're talking about
this much force moving this fast there's
very few things that can stand in the
way of it and this is designed to
highlight a couple of different things
well it does kind of show that the
flashes are moving exceedingly fast the
real big takeaway from this is it like
Green Lantern can't stop him Superman
can't catch him if we ran into a
situation with a flash
truly decided that he wanted to be a
villain and just unleash holy hell
across the world there wouldn't really
be a whole lot of people who can stop
him like there really wouldn't be a
whole lot of people that could get in
his way and this is really more I
imagine if like vindication for flash
fans right like I've been telling people
for years the flash is one of the
strongest characters are is and nobody
ever want to leave it that's really
where this kind of fits in here because
you're talking about a person who's so
fast and moving is such an incredible
speed that really people are just in the
way and that's that's really all it
comes down to so again it's a really
interesting moment here but one of the
things to bear in mind is it really is
Barry trying to impart this wisdom on
Diwali that's really what he's trying to
do here I mean you're talking about a
guy who's been around for a long time
and he was learning how to be the flash
when he first came to speed and he was
understanding what it meant to be a hero
that there would be times when your
moral compass would be questioned but
you always have to do the right thing me
Oh Barry had walked those walk that path
he'd walked that road Wally
picked up after Barry you know Wally
gained his powers as a little kid and
Barry was imparting all that wisdom on
him when he was a little kid when he was
kid flash and then when Barry died
during crisis on Infinite Earths or at
least was believed to have died Wally
took up the pieces you know he
particular pieces took up the mantle
became the new flash and he had to
discover all those things on his own but
it's not like there's really a right or
wrong here it's not there's no it's
really one of those very hairy morally
ambiguous middle grounds it's very much
a gray area because on 1/2 the
speedforce being destroyed
who knows what effect it would have on
the multiverse and so like you're
talking about this idea that like the
Speed Force could literally destroy the
entire fabric of creation and while
Barry's trying to stop Wally from doing
that at the same time Wally's trying to
rescue his kids and it makes perfect
sense
you know Speed Force and universe be
damned Wally wants to find his kids and
it's a it's a perfect thing is it's
exactly what any parent would do and
that's why it makes it so cool and
that's one of the reasons why I like
looking at this this whole situation
unfolding this is why Wally West always
had his dedicated fan base as a reason
why fans always loved Wally because what
you're talking about here is a character
that's so emotional in a lot of ways and
is so grounded and so rooted that was
really the big difference between Barry
and Wally I mean looking back at the
earlier days of comics Barry was very
ground and he was very tangible you know
but really he was more of like the
iconic superhero he was he was born and
bred in the age of 1950s science-fiction
meets superhero themes he was the one
that really reinvigorated interest in
comic books you know what DC showcased
number four and so without him
like wall-e was a lot more grounded he
was a lot more tangible because by the
time he became the new flash in the mid
to late 1980s it was really a wholly
different era of comics when Stacey had
died Dark Knight Returns was about to
kick off you had like all these things
that had been going on that it made
heroes a lot darker and a lot more
gritty and a lot more real-world and
realistic and so those themes were
rolled over into the Wally West comics
that combined with the fact that
everybody loved him from Justice League
Unlimited and all that kind of all kind
of stuff it basically meant that you had
a recipe for like everyone's favorite
flash and so that's why people loved
Wally so much but from there you
essentially have Wally who succeeds
like literally seems to break through
the Speed Force and shadow the Speed
Force in its entirety the problem with
this is that's not what happens the
Speed Force is not broken and it's not
destroyed the Speed Force is still very
much there instead what is up happening
here is hunter zolomon essentially
appears but after taking out all the
members of the Justice League and the
reason why is because the sky is kind of
shattered it's basically broken and
where the belief is that the Speed Force
is broken what hundreds element says is
that's not what's going on here what's
actually going on here is I want it like
I basically lied to you and it was the
most predictable outcome there was
really no point where were Joshua
Williams or Wilson believed that we
would believe that hunter zolomon had
become a good guy he's just like that
incorrigible unchangeable villain and so
as a matter of just kind of seeing how
this situation would play out and hunter
zolomon response is you guys believe
there's only the Speed Force but that's
not true
there's the strength force there's
there's the sage force there's all these
different forces out there now this
actually makes a whole lot of sense when
you really break it down and the reason
why I say this is the Speed Force is the
most prominent force just because of the
fact that you're talking about like how
the house speedsters draw their power
but with regards to to this whole this
whole concept if speedsters draw their
their super speed from the Speed Force
then where do you like super strong
characters draw their energy from where
do you like psychics draw their energy
from that's why this works so well is
shuffling up the status quo is changing
things up a bit what Joshua Williamson
is doing here is the flash equivalent to
Geoff Johns expanding on the Green
Lantern Court and saying now there's a
Red Lantern core in a Sinestro Corps and
then black lanterns or white lanterns
and Indigo's and blue blue lanterns of
star sapphires and all these kind of
things you know that's that's why it
works is because it's expanding on this
mythos they could really even go beyond
the flash mythos itself but at the
moment what hunter zolomon had been
doing was studying
the entire really the history of like
the world you know of what have been
going on over the course of like decades
and decades and decades running up to
the 25th century and what this means is
that hunter zolomon is aware of dr.
Manhattan he's aware of like the war
that will take place at least it seems
like he is as though his whole argument
is we need like an actual hero a true
hero you guys are not heroes you guys
are standing in for heroes you're
parading around you're not really
solving anything you're just running
around in circles hoping things change
but he's like eyes basically like the
whole point behind this was to have you
guys smash through this quote-unquote
force barrier so the Speed Force is
still there but what you've done is
you've now released the sage force and
you've released the strength force and
what it means is that hunter zolomon can
now tap into these things and what that
means now is hunter zolomon has
telepathy and telekinesis hunter zolomon
has super strength and hunter zolomon
has super speed he's literally just like
Superman
amplified several times over with the
powers of Martian Manhunter this guy is
a walking talking God on earth but
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys hit this up button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you